cuéntenos más que la concientización y
sensibilización sobre este tema qué
necesitan en concreto las mujeres que
padecen esta enfermedad
Muchísimas gracias por la invitación
Andrés para mí es un gusto compartir con
ustedes el cáncer es la tercera causa de
muerte a nivel mundial en nuestro país
se detectan te quiero platicar 191 mil
casos de cáncer cada año y el cáncer de
mama y el cáncer de próstata son de los
de los más comunes Entonces es súper
importante invertir nuestros recursos y
nuestro tiempo en la detección y la
atención oportuna de este diagnóstico a
nivel global Gabriela la lucha contra
esta enfermedad se ha visto afectada por
la pandemia de Kobe 19 Sí por supuesto
de hecho tenemos una cifras que te
quiero compartir también de México pero
bueno Esto se replicó a nivel mundial
según la Organización Mundial de la
Salud
en el 2021 se detectaron
11.746 casos de cáncer de mama y
comparados con el 2020 fueron
8.723 esto quiere decir que la cifra un
35% Y sí se vio un aumento de los casos
derivado de la pandemia ahora cuál es el
balance que hace sobre por ejemplo los
métodos de prevención y atención que
brindan los gobiernos del mundo a las
mujeres y hombres que también padecen o
han padecido actualmente o parecen
actualmente esta batalla contra la
enfermedad
Pues mira Más allá de hablar de
prevención digo
a que nuestras células lleven a cabo un
proceso normal de apoptosis que es de
muerte celular pero es muy complicado
hablar de un tema de prevención más bien
se habla detección oportuna Porque si se
pudiera prevenir como tal prácticamente
No tendríamos tanto problema con este
con este diagnóstico no se recomienda
muchísimo que se brinde la atención
médica oportuna en todos los países del
mundo en México ahorita desgraciadamente
estamos pasando por una crisis de
nuestro sistema de salud Ya que la
administración actual quito el seguro
popular ya que también quitaron el el
fideicomiso de gastos catastróficos lo
cual cubría una atención y detección
oportuna del cáncer Entonces no hay
suficiente equipo médico ni
especialistas en zonas marginadas de
nuestro país y creo que eso puede ayudar
muchísimo para la atención oportuna no
También estamos sufriendo un problema
importante de desabasto en medicamentos
oncológicos lo cual pues afecta también
el tema de la atención oportuna porque
te es detectar el cáncer pero si no si
vas a un hospital público y no se
encuentran con los medicamentos y con
los recursos para tratarlo Pues el
panorama no es tan sencillo no entonces
Ojalá que podamos hacer un llamado a
todas las autoridades a nivel mundial
para que en el caso de los países como
México puedan apoyar
Pues de alguna manera hacer un llamado
para que se pueda brindar la atención
oportuna que merecemos todos los
ciudadanos no y no solamente en este
país también en otros países que sea una
campaña muy exitosa para que realmente
se pueda atender con tiempo porque eso
puede cambiar la historia no según la
Organización Mundial de la Salud se
pueden este salvar cuatro de cada 10
casos provocados por cáncer y en México
desgraciadamente el 70% de los del
cáncer de mama se detecta muy tarde
ahora no está de más también recordarle
a nuestros televidentes Cuáles son esas
señales de alerta
Pues mira es muy importante primero
usarse el autoexploración recordar que
el cáncer de mama no es únicamente en
mujeres también se puede dar en hombres
es importante ver que la mamá no está
enrojecida que no exista ningún bulto
que se vea a simple vista en la
autoexploración hay que revisar que el
pezón tenga una forma normal que no está
enrojecida que no salgan líquidos
anormales como puede ser sangre como
líquido blanco líquido amarillo que
puede llegar a salir por el pezón que no
tengamos dolor todos estos son síntomas
que pueden generar una alerta en este
diagnóstico